certifications have served as a stepping
stone for anybody seeking to advance in
their careers whether they are beginners
or seasoned professionals according to
robert haff's 2021 it salary report i.t
professionals with certifications earn 5
to 10 more than their peers
so in this video we'll go over the
finest certifications that can help you
attain a good compensation package
next up we have number five big data
big data is a discipline that permits
the analysis extraction and management
of massive and complex data collections
the following are some common
certifications that you can pursue
the associate certified analytics
professional credential allows you to
begin the analytics process it focuses
on many analytics areas such as business
issue framing analytics problem framing
and many more
you could also pick up the ccp data
engineer certification
this certificate allows you to
demonstrate your knowledge of ingesting
transforming storing and analyzing data
in cloudera's cdh environment a big data
engineer can earn 121 thousand to
251 thousand dollars per annum in the
united states
in india he or she can earn close to
12.3 lakh to 33 lakh rupees per annum
with the right certification
at number four we have digital marketing
businesses can only succeed if their
targeted customers are aware of their
product or services
thus digital marketing is an essential
component of every company's operations
as the area of marketing has evolved in
the digital era the demand for experts
who have been trained in new abilities
has increased substantially a digital
marketing certification can help you
hone the skills such as seo ppc web
analytics content marketing and social
media
let's now have a look at some of the
best certifications you can pick up
first off you can take up simplylearn's
digital marketing specialist masters
certification or you can take up
certifications such as google ad
certification google analytics
certification and hubspot content
marketing certification
all of these certifications touch upon
concepts of digital marketing such as
seo
content marketing ppc digital analytics
social media and so much more
a digital marketing manager could earn
sixty thousand to a hundred and sixty
thousand in the united states and up to
seven lakh to 16 lakh rupees per annum
in india
next we have number three data science
it is a branch of computer science that
integrates scientific techniques
algorithms and systems to extract
information and insights from organized
and unstructured data
let's look at a few top certifications
that you can pick up for this domain
first and foremost there is ibm's data
science professional certification this
ibm backed certification may help you
get started with data science python sql
data analysis and visualization building
machine learning tools and much more
harvardx's data science professional
certificate is another option for
accreditation
it will cover our programming data
visualization essential data science
tools machine learning methods
probability inference and much more by
choosing the right certification a data
scientist can earn up to 115 000 to 246
000 in the united states and 8.2 lakh to
20 lakh in india
now for number two let's have a look at
cloud computing
no other area of it has produced as much
hype excitement and investment as cloud
computing during the last decade
according to idc by next year cloud will
attain a growth rate of 22
and a value of 277
billion dollars
and because of this there will
undoubtedly be a high demand for cloud
experts
some of the popular cloud computing
certifications you can pick up are the
aws certified solutions architect
associate certification
this certification will enhance your
ability to architect deploy
and secure applications on aws
to use the appropriate architecture
designs and much more you can also look
into the microsoft certified azure
administration certification which is
ideal for people who want to manage
cloud services that cover storage
security networking and cloud
capabilities
a cloud computing engineer can earn up
to 145 000 to
227 000 in the united states and earn
close to 16 lakh to 24 lakh rupees in
india with the right certification
and finally we're at number one ai and
machine learning
what if machines can provide you with
optimal data-driven decisions by
perceiving patterns in previous data
sets
how amazing will this be right
this astounding fact about ai and ml
domain has made it one of the most
popular career choices
in the previous year's trends ai has
shown a staggering 344
growth and the right certification can
help you do wonders in this amazing
domain a few of them are simply learns
postgraduate program in ai and machine
learning created in partnership with
purdue university and in collaboration
with ibm covers a number of concepts
like statistics python machine learning
deep learning networks nlp reinforcement
learning and more
machine learning ai certification by
stanford available on coursera is also a
good resource this course includes an
introduction to machine learning data
mining statistical pattern recognition
the best practices in machine learning
and ai etc
an ai engineer can earn 140 000 to
386 000 in the united states and six to
20 lakh rupees in india with that we've
reached the end of this video do you
agree with our list think we missed
anything important let us know in the
comment section below
thank you for watching the video and
stay tuned for more from simplylearn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simplylearn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here